even now when i when i don't have the
best of games
my dad's first on the on the tech's
telling me
[Music]
okay stepovers takes him on chops
another one
goes inside great finish
it's funny how the defenders lay on the
floor at the end
especially the first one i think he goes
down like he's rolled his ankle he's
been twisted up that much
oh that's unbelievable i'm sure the
defender won't be happy there
in training you can feel a bit
embarrassed because it's your it's your
mate doing it you know when you go back
to the dressing room they're going to
bring it up in the
in the conversations and have a little
bit of battle with you so when you get
beat by a good piece of skill
when someone puts it through your legs
it's always a little bit more
embarrassing we have a lot of lads who
like to nutmeg in our team to be fair
especially in training i say marcus
rashford's probably the best day in our
in our team
um he's always trying it and looking for
it it's a good way to beat an opponent
nowadays to be fair but
you know he gets a lot of joy from it
especially in training
he's lining up like he's got a little
bit
i don't know what happens but it's even
better that the guy's just sitting in
the corner
i remember robert hoof doing this with
leicester and someone showed me a video
i signed the year later but he
he could hit a ball really well houthi
in training
and i think he took a free kick and it
went something like this and the lads
showed me and always still getting
banner so i'm sure the guy who's done
that he's probably still getting sticked
to this day
don't keep down the pitch oh no
it's an own goal i'm sure he'll be
disappointed
i can remember playing at that age and i
still was competitive i wanted to win
every game
i'm sure his biggest critics will
probably be his parents like mine were
even now when i when i don't have the
best of games
my dad's first on the on the text
telling me
so you've played with some obviously
really amazing keepers
in your time so far who's the best that
you've played with
the best i've played with i would go
with for what
he's done in the game he's david for
sure at manchester united
great career spain's number one been
player of the season
numerous times at manchester united and
thoroughly deserved so
now he's great to play in front of the
experience that he's got seen him pull
off many saves like that especially
in training and games
[Applause]
strike's unbelievable reminds me of it
as paul scholes when he did it back in
the day
on the edge of the box from the corner i
don't know who these players are but
like
they're fully signed for this have you
ever scored a day like that
definitely not i'd leave that to
probably in our team
i think bruno would be the one who's got
the technique to execute something like
that
in third place i've gone with the
the free kick which finds the guy i
think walking his dog on the chest
it's um
it's got to be the funniest clip i've
seen so i've got i've got to put in my
top three
and second i've gone for the for the
left wingers trickery
just because he puts their two defenders
laying down on
on the back side and i'm sure they're
not pleased with that at all they know
it's great playing
and great skill from him the first place
i've gone for the volley i think this is
probably
the best technique the best skill um the
way they've executed well he's actually
under pressure from
from the guy who's closed him down as
well so i think for sure that's the
hardest to execute especially
because he was under pressure as well
i'm aaron maguire and that was rate my
skills for sport bible
[Music]
you